hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and tonight
I wouldn't saw no tonight I went and saw
Bohemian Rhapsody since starting Tamra's
never seen in Tamara just saw a lot of
people have wanted me to branch out and
do other things like video games and
music so here's a small episode of
tamara has heard and it's Queen this is
not my shirt I stole this from the chain
awesome studio I'm pretty sure it's like
one of Jim's old shirts so I stole it
and I borrowed it I borrowed it I'm
returning it back Jim I promise maybe I
like a lot of Queen fans and character
study in film fans have been I think
very excited about this film I was
seeing bad times at the El Royale and
Bohemian Rhapsody trailer played for the
film and I looked at the friend that I
was seeing it with I was like I wish we
were seeing this instead I don't even
want to see the movie we're seeing right
now I'm so pumped to see this film the
movie however was kind of mess but I
still had fun
it felt so rushed but I still cried at
the end it was a terrible script get the
actors made it work it was a whole
hodgepodge of things that make a movie
bad and somehow I think it's still
prevailed but it was on that cusp of
just not at all prevailing even the wise
words of Rob Walker Bohemian Rhapsody is
an awesome Queen music video constantly
interrupted by a dull Bryan Singer movie
great music video though and damn it if
he didn't just like beat me to the punch
with that one perfectly stated perfectly
stated absolutely true it was thrilling
to watch the music and to watch the
acting
in the music videos portions of this and
them putting together Bohemian Rhapsody
and then putting together all of these
incredible songs and then it was
terrible terrible dialogue and scripts
work throughout the rest of it which
surprises me because it's arguably to
some I would for me personally I think
he's the best frontman ever Freddie
Mercury I know this is about Queen as a
whole but let's be honest it's about
Freddie Mercury and so to take someone
so weird so unique so bizarre and out
there and fun and fresh and different
new and then to put him in this cookie
cutter of a script was just so weird
I think the actor really was able to
somehow work magic with it because he
was completely believable as the role as
were the other band members I know that
the actual band members who are still
around they had a big part in this and
they have been pushing through this film
they were like if we don't make it
somebody else is gonna do it poorly and
so you know the story on its own is such
an intriguing rise to fame with such an
intriguing person and a character study
of this human and so for them to take
just this really interesting thing that
I think 90% of us going into this film
really wanted it to be like a character
piece about Freddie Mercury I might be
wrong on that maybe I just really wanted
that but knowing full well it was going
to be about Queen as a whole and less
about his personal struggles it was
still like mostly him but I wanted it to
be less of this rush to get through like
hey I just joined to this band the
smiles and now we're Queen and now oh my
god all of a sudden were writing
Bohemian Rhapsody and oh my god now we
have this deal and oh my god now we're
touring the u.s. and I just like really
rushed and like meet my beat by beat by
beat is this weird rushed thing we're so
much happened in his life and they put
too much in it and not enough they put
too many like big milestones and not
enough
like small mundane you know struggles I
think for me and yet because the story
is so damn engaging at the end I still
found myself tearing up crying it like
the build-up of like oh you reconciled
with his family and oh my god they did
the whole aids live event and oh it's so
beautiful and I cried throughout the
whole thing it was beautiful and great
at because the acting was stellar and
it's very powerful to have this story
being told through music it's just the
parts that weren't a meeting for oh not
spectacular I will say that I know a lot
of people were worried about them doing
some by erasure and some queer erasure
in the film not focusing on his
struggles with AIDS or his you know
sexuality that was on my mind after
seeing the trailer and I know a lot of
people still think that after seeing the
film I will say personally that's if it
was a character piece on just him I
think I would be very disappointed just
overall but I kiss here if it was a
character piece just hey might I would
definitely agree for what the movie was
I thought that it touched on it and a
good amount but you know nothing the
parts of this movie that worked are when
we see him in his glory and when we see
this amazing actor just crushing it as
this character it's so engaging because
we all feel at least if you're a fan of
Freddy Mercury you feel like you you
know him right
so it's engaging to watch someone really
portray him well in my opinion that's
what those are the person I found really
really engaging it all just happened so
fast like I said all of the beats are
just like bam bam bam bam here we are
we're doing this this this this this
this proposed to marry record this song
record the album getting signed you go
on this tour record another thing go to
this barn realize your sexuality
so many things all at once and it
doesn't play like any of these things
mean
very much there's one point where he
proposes to marry and then they get this
US tour and both of these things are
giant things but they all happen so
close to each other that it's like I
don't feel the weight of any of this I
don't feel like this is a giant triumph
because it's happening so fast and I
don't know what they should have done to
remedy that because I know so many
things did happen and there's so much
they want to get through to get you at
least the timeline that they got you at
the end where they're doing the live
show but I don't know you know it's just
not the character piece that I want for
Freddie Mercury man like I said there's
a lot of rushed things if there's a lot
of you know things that aren't done well
at all but there's one thing that really
just doesn't fit in the movie whereas
they all kind of they all fit in this
cookie cutter thing and then there's
this one scene where Freddy is throwing
a party and it's kind of meant to show
you how him in the band kind of find
conflict and how he is not meshing well
in his life he's kind of feeling
isolated and he meets his partner in the
scene a lot of things are happening that
need to happen but the scene itself is
made you to feel kind of uncomfortable
with Freddy like he's being very
flamboyant which he was and the
bandmates are kind of like you're being
a jerk man you're being a jerk and they
leave the party and you know you don't
feel like they're the family that
they've been saying that they are and it
feels like you're made to feel kind of
upset at Freddy him and kind of like
your psyche siding with the band and I
didn't like that at all not saying that
I feel like we should have sided with
Freddy the whole time not saying that he
was a perfect man not saying that he
didn't have faults and that like I can't
feel any like negativity towards him
this scene was just weird it just felt
like what are we doing here what's the
point of this I feel like they're trying
to like pit us against his like
flamboyancy which is weird cuz that's
who he is so that was very odd I didn't
enjoy that scene at all I wrote and you
know I couldn't help but cry and be
through the entire concert show not
through the writing or directing or the
film but because of the man and because
of the incredible performer that he was
and the insane story that his life was
and that's the end of my notes that's
what I wrote all because of a man that
this movie is any good at all and the
band of course but I think they
discredited him a lot to not just show
all of his weirdnesses and all of his
you know flamboyant TSA's and all of his
is--is I am the cat of the apartment
do do do do what I'm doing I'm gonna
keep me alone till you feed me doo doo
doo doo doo doo
I am a cat I am The King no time for
cables
I need wet food cuz I'm the kid thank
you so much for watching everyone I will
see you next week with I'm not gonna
pretend like I know bye
[Music]